it's finally here the first Captain
Marvel trailer featuring hashtag creel
arson so let's break this baby down and
see what we can find the trailer begins
with what appears to be an escape pod
fleeing a giant explosion this is likely
carol danvers 'as pas de que captain
marvel played by brie Larson since the
next shot we have is of her crash
landing into a blockbuster
judging from the skyline and palm trees
we're likely in Southern California and
let's not forget blockbuster itself
which suggests the film will take place
in the 1990s we also get a first glimpse
of her costume which surprisingly isn't
the traditional red yellow and blue
rather green silver and grey this likely
has to do with her Kree based origins
and potentially a tie-in to the plot of
Avengers 4 we do know whoever that
she'll eventually dawn the traditional
Captain Marvel costume she stands in
front of a large action sign as if
foreshadowing the action that awaits her
beyond those doors as Nick Fury says war
is a universal language people give her
weird looks in the subway suggesting
that this is shortly after her trip to
Blockbuster that she doesn't know where
she is and worst of all she didn't pick
up any movies for 9.99 everyone is
wearing 90s clothing and this dude even
has a Walkman you can also see the stop
for 7th Street Metro Center which is a
stop in the Los Angeles subway system
Nick Fury talks about her being a
renegade soldier hinting at a possible
class she had with her people on the
Kree homeworld or perhaps even on earth
and it looks like he recruits her taking
her to a top secret underground facility
that is working on alien technology here
you can see an early version of the
agents of shield logo on Captain
Marvel's hat we then get quick glimpses
of an alien spaceship descending over
the California coast
whoever Captain Marvel pissed off
they're coming for not to mention the
images accompanied by Nick Fury saying
the words space invasion here you can
see Nick Fury icing his head holding an
alien weapon suggesting he was the one
who caught whatever is on that operating
table we get a few quick shots of what I
believe to be two separate chases a car
chase featuring Nick Fury and Phil
Coulson and a foot pursuit where we see
Captain Marvel use one of her powers
harnessing the energy of a white hole
allowing full control and manipulation
of stellar energies Nick was going to
hand in
badge until he met her and we see him
take off his shades to reveal both eyes
are intact Marvel has also implemented
their D ageing technology on Samuel
Jackson just like they did to Robert
Downey jr. in Captain America Civil War
we then get our first glimpse of a Kree
ship descending on what could be their
home world of Halle
Captain Marvel has flashes of memories
hinting at her past in the United States
Air Force we even get a glimpse of what
could be Monica Rambeau a character who
took the alias of Captain Marvel after
the death of the character in the 1982
graphic novel we see her crash on what
seems to be as a mysterious energy takes
control of her if you remember Carol got
her powers after the DNA fused with
Marvel's during an explosion giving her
superhuman powers could this be that
explosion she then looks to be in prison
her hands confined and brain continually
zapped with electromagnetic power I'm
wondering if this is the ship she's on
before the explosion we saw at the
beginning of the trailer we then see
Captain Marvel looking badass with their
fellow creased soldiers before we see
Marvel played here by Jude Law not
looking impressed I'm wondering if she's
been sent to stop him especially since
these set photos from Entertainment
Weekly show him in cahoots with Ronan
the accuser the villain from guardians
of the galaxy after a brief glimpse of a
circus tent we see Carol's transition
from stunt driver Air Force pilot look
you can even make out the clouds in her
visors reflection and then space pilot
she even holds up the peace sign but
what she's looking at we don't know then
we see a Skrull an extraterrestrial race
of shapeshifters that have likely landed
on earth for nefarious purposes this
likely explains why she punches the old
lady although it would be hilarious if
she wasn't a scroll we then get this
shot of Ronan the accuser overlooking
earth which could be from the same ship
we saw earlier before were treated to
agent Phil Coulson Nick Fury's
second-in-command let's all give a big
shout out to the sweet new technology
beepers Captain Marvel and her crew look
as if they've just made their way from
this underwater ship on a mission you
can see our costume here looks eerily
similar to the comics and now what might
be the most important part of the
trailer the explosion here seems to
transfer powers to Carol it looks like
she might have been trying to save
whatever or whoever was in that pod we
then get this
brief glimpse of no it's not Batman Kara
wearing a sikh mask holding on for dear
life one of the things trailers rarely
do is reveal character and this final
montage of child carol recruit carol air
force carol and finally captain marvel
show us that this is someone who doesn't
give up she brushes herself off and
tries again even if it means getting
hurt so even though this trailer didn't
give away much of the plot nor showcase
the main villain i think it still says a
lot of where this film is going and what
kind of ride we'll be in for i'm sure i
missed a lot of stuff here guys i want
you to leave your comments below and let
me know what you think I hope you'll
stay tuned with me for more breakdowns
and deep dives and as always if you
liked this video give it a thumbs up
until next time